pendant que vladimir poutine mène une
guerre sans merci au nom d'une
soi-disant dénazification de l'ukraine
justin trudeau en visite à berlin
constate lui les horreurs du régime nazi
pendant quatre ans entre 1941 et 1945
cette plateforme la 17 était un point de
départ important vers les camps de la
mort le premier ministre canadien se
recueillent sans dire un mot il annonce
quelques heures plus tard que volodymyr
zelensky qu'est d'ailleurs de confession
juive pourra s'exprimer au parlement
canadien
je lui ai lancé l'invitation cours d'un
appel téléphonique explique justin
trudeau et il a accepté la date reste
encore à déterminer mais dans
l'entourage du premier ministre on
indique que ça ne serait tarder aux
côtés du nouveau chancelier allemand
justin trudeau débloque également 50
millions de dollars supplémentaires qui
serviront à fournir de l'équipement
militaire à l'ukraine nous avons obtenu
des caméras produite au canada qui vont
pouvoir aider les ukrainiens sur des
drones dans leur défense de leur pays
l'allemagne elle aussi envoyé des armes
une rupture majeure avec la politique
étrangère pacifiste qu'elle avait adopté
depuis la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
notre ferme face à bladimir poutine
reste difficile quand on ici dépendant
du pétrole et du gaz russe costumes
probléme et le c'est un défi pour nous à
court et moyen terme reconnaît
chancelier allemand centre d'où
d'ailleurs ne ferme pas la porte à
cheminer éventuellement des
hydrocarbures canadien vers l'europe oui
le canada a des ressources en énergies
fossiles nous sommes là à pour pour
aider dans le besoin au pied de la porte
de brandebourg pendant longtemps un
symbole de division en europe le premier
ministre canadien se dit convaincu que
le crâne va finir par l'emporter ce
conflit qui affligent de nouveau le
continent et ce même si justin trudeau
comme tant d'autres refusent de donner
au président ukrainien ce qu'il estime
essentiel la fermeture de l'espace
aérien ou de son pays et si leur en
sortait radio-canada à berlin